c'est dans la journée ça c'est que c'est
bernard montiel parce que la quote part
aux pirates des caraïbes lui c'est
plutôt de le pirate qui revient des
caraïbes douvres alors et donc oui vous
vous rendez vous
non si lé papier de la personne à qui ça
appartient d'accord votre moi ces pièces
de monnaie on sait même pas de quelle
époque elles sont donc c'est très
compliqué à revendre et ce que je veux
dire autrement moi je garde tout c'est
faux c'était pas terrible alors vous
vous êtes on l'a redit ce coquet
coquette mais ça faisait des ménages
merci à vous on est rendu là rassurant
moi je suis né flip est est ce qu'il y
avait à boire j'avais absolue de cry
d'err que ça peut appartenir on sait
jamais si ces gens la maaf carette et
vous croyez quoi vous pouvez vraiment
clair inspiration à revenir dans le jeu
non non non jamais il ne dit pas prêt
dans la presse il apprend où il voit où
il s'est vu ni marie thibeault rendra
moins honnêtes vous dire moi ce que
j'aurais fait dans un instant mais vous
le savez vous éventuellement si les
papiers je demande de rançon
autrement je garde tout alors le c'est
sale ça déjà le sait ça l'année dernière
ils ont trouvé trois millions
[Applaudissements]
maintenant on va surtout c'est le sait
laisser ça là bas on va boire et dont
les cci ont mis un petit tri comme ça
devant les programmes télé se sont
arrêtés et attaqués nous non honnêtement
moi je trouve genre je suis un peu
vraiment quand valérie j'aurais peur à
un centime je prends un franc je prends
10 10 euros je prends 500 et bidart je
prône un rouge commence à apprendre en
regardant un côté adacore là franchement
je rends en quoi vous en faites années
30 d'accor en mousquetaire mousquetaires
d'artagnan d'artagnan vous êtes en art à
nous j'avance ou et à porto ce à côté de
vous valérie berthod vous êtes je suis
en dresseur de truffe évoluent une
autruche dans le sypol dans le slip
c'est de la vraie mise en scène connais
je reconnais que la production ils ont
tout dire qu'est ce qu'on a comme que tu
veux t'en dit yann un costume boutruche
on peut pas penser avant et battons-nous
truche vous ont rendu l'argent
non j'aurais photographier les pièces de
monnaie je les aurai troqué est comme
suit un très grand négociateur allait
ramener il aurait été dans l'émission de
sophie davant
affaire conclue basser as well bon c'est
bon oui tu parle pour toi tu connais moi
je vole qua non je vous explique j'en
parle pas à la presse
donc pas de soucis personne n'est au
courant je récupère les pièces j'ai fait
fondre je les fais en lingots ensuite je
vais voir des bijouteries
je vais voir quel prix on me propose et
c'est ça ne suffit pas bah je pense que
j'ai dans un autre pays essaie de les
revendre aux meilleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sézanne commerce avec ahmed et l'angola
dégage de gaulle et jusqu'à plus faire
marie antoinette ça lui a pas réussi à
ses valeurs justement c'est ton mari ou
toilettes l'archiduchesse autrichienne
ouais jean marie antoinette morte à 37
ans guillotine sa vie a été quand même
un sacré drame et sa wii mais vraiment
c'est faire honneur ce smart
alors ok que vous avez devant vous
soumet antonetti où elle est morte en
voilà et ce qui est marrant c'est que la
veille de son 200e 18 12 704
marie-antoinette elle est morte en 1993
éléments sur la macarena
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la tête est emprisonné à la conciergerie
droit et la veille de la veille de sa
décapitation l'a fait venir le son
bourreau soumah et lobo samson et lui a
donné une bourse s'en sont échappés
ouais c'est une bourse remplie de pièces
dans dix ans bourreau aiguise bien ta
l'âme et une fois montés sur les
chapeaux sur la charité chaque rôle à
ses dernières paroles
elle est montée sur des chapeaux chapeau
elle est montée la marche est
malencontreusement sur le pied de son
bureau il est bientôt pardon par dennis
a cédé après la décrypter ces derniers
mots salima antoine est un petit peu
d'histoire ne fait pas de mal on n'a pas
aimé c'est mon personnage est un
transsexuel qua non pas ça non plus
rassuré qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
république lui a fait couper la tête
parce que
enfin ces enfants sont morts aussi ils
ont tué les enfants parce que les gens
ils ont tué les enfants parce qu'il ne
fallait pas qu'ils aient d'héritier ils
ont décapité tout le monde voilà surtout
il faut dire que cette femme était
accusée par le pop de dépenser l'argent
oui la france est donc on va pas quand
même plein de marijuana lui plaisait à
la vallée moreau accusés de tromperie et
d'orge ivan excusez moi c'est une
spéciale précision à l'époque il
n'allait pas aux toilettes
oui et en portugais avait juste à se
mettre debout comme ça me faisait pipi
non non non non c'est gilles qui met et
au début de son mariage avec louis saez
ils sont restés plusieurs années sans
pouvoir faire l'amour celui là bim
anomalie c'est la reine doute riches à
devenir leur expliquer comment on
faisait des emplois qu il avait un
phimosis ils pouvaient pas sauter
tellement douloureux quand il faisait
l'amour mais une petite anomalie qui
essaie d un monde douloureux quand il
faisait l'amour qu'il voulait pas le
faire ça lui rappelle attend un malade
au roulement
du coup il avait les hématomes
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est les marseillais font l'histoire
[Rires]
c'est que c'est dix fois les marseillais
car en compte l'histoire allait certes
un peu sur terre et c'est pour cela
qu'on attends attends attends ça faisait
beaucoup rigolé merci et et fait moins
de bruit quand vous sortez nous tasser
cruciaux de rêverie
c'est bon c'est quoi la basse
non vous vous rendez l'argent non enfin
je le rends mais je veux une récompense
déjà dans un modèle qui vous vous prenez
brawn et l'oreille déjà vous avez acheté
plein de cadeaux à fatma oui il reste
quelque chose
voilà je demande 10 % du montant total
comme récompense
oui oui vous faites quoi vous à moi je
demande de rien j'espère que c'est une
vrai fou trouve retrouvailles
historiques et que les gens diront a été
découvert en telle année par isabelle
morani passe que traverse même pas
l'esprit de le rendre ah oui je garde
j'ai expertise en secret et après je
dépense petit à petit stack taxe nous
souhaitons pour vous en chaperon rouge
sa poule la vie en entier c'est la voir
en entier
avant-hier voit bien on voit le petit
chapeau bas elle va elle va danser tout
aaa à carreaux et magnifique n'a pas
besoin d'être petit chaperon rouge pour
être magnifique
elle est belle même en petit au chaperon
ou même en rouge ou alors vous comme on
fait alors lui en fait et on s'est dit
on va jouer sur ajouter des bâtons
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs vous alors je vous le dis
vous partez tout de suite en relooking
battus et nous partagerons lounging au
jour en plein la tête
j'ai envie de le voir j'en ai envie de
le voir ça fait des années qu'on ne voit
plus je veux le voir c'est un bon gars
j'en avais le bonnet pour coiffer je
veux le voir maquillées bon je veux le
voir à bout
[Applaudissements]